Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more
people in the audience. How about Ramiro
from Indiana? Welcome back to the program, sir.
Ramiro, please accept my invitation
to join the program. There is.
Speaker 2: They're sorry about that. So my quick
question is. So Donald Trump, everything going
on? Obviously, you know, there's nothing in place
that would prevent him from running for president,
even from prison, correct?
Speaker 1: That's that's my understanding, yeah.
Speaker 2: So is that is there a reason for is
it simply because there isn't a specific law in
the books for that? Or is it a conscious effort
to say, prevent something like let's just for
example, if Donald Trump, when he won in 2016,
let's say 2020, he was running against Hillary
again and he was afraid that she would beat him.
So like he would jail his political prisoner,
like saying lock her up in an attempt to. I guess
so. Is that the reason? Something like that, a law
preventing that from happening? Is it in place?
Speaker 1: That's a good question, which is is
the reason why you're allowed to run for
president from prison, that it prevents
someone from jailing a political opponent
to get them out of a race? Yeah. So that's
not my understanding of the reasoning why I, I
think the reasoning is a lot kind of less less
exciting, which is the principle of law that if
something isn't banned, then it's allowed. And
since nothing expressly bans someone from
being in prison and running for president,
it's allowed. We've never really had a
situation in which I think someone would
actually have a shot at winning the way
Trump would. But I'll be honest, Ramiro,
it's a very interesting question. I don't think
it's going to play out in any real way because
I don't think Trump's going to be in prison.
Speaker 2: No, and I don't either. Yeah, I don't
either. But I guess I wanted to know your opinion.
Do you think that that law should be in place or
like I said, do you think it shouldn't be in place
to possibly prevent something like a Bolsonaro
trying to jail Lula da Silva and all that stuff?
Speaker 1: Generally speaking, generally speaking,
I'm okay with the requirements to be president
being super, super basic. Now, remember, I'm not
allowed to run for president because I wasn't born
in the United States. I could make the argument
actually, that should be changed, but forget
about me. I'm not even arguing. Just in general,
you know, age and natural born citizen. Okay. I
actually think that I don't want to be putting
a whole bunch of new requirements on, although
I am obviously ideologically interested in the
idea of some kind of composite competency test
which might have ruled out Donald Trump. But the
one thing that's a little crazy for me is if in
some states, if you're a felon, you can't vote,
but yet you could be a convicted felon and people
vote for you and you win. Something about that
seems a little incongruous. You know, it's weird.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah, that's funny. And that's
why I ask the question. Because if you
would have asked me before 2016. Yeah,
I would have said yeah. No, you should absolutely
not be able to run for president if you're Joe.
But then I got to thinking. I'm like, right. You
know, with him running his campaign screaming,
Lock her up, lock her up. And I got to thinking,
you know, maybe that's maybe it's a good thing
that that's not on the books. But it is
funny that you can be in prison and not
be allowed to vote after you get out. It's yeah.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, there's a lot of these weird,
incongruous things, but it's I think the point
we both come away with is the next 18 months
are going to be pretty insane.
Speaker 2: Yeah, absolutely.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend. Thank you
for the call. Taking my call. Appreciate
it. There is Ramiro from Indiana. Why don't
we go next to Casey from Kansas? Casey from
Kansas. Welcome back to the program.
Speaker 2: Hello. Hello? Yeah,
I just have a simple question this time. Sure.
You already covered it a little bit on your show.
Do you think what the when of Brandon Johnson
in Chicago against his more tough on crime
more police endorsed by the Fraternal
Order candidate. Do you think that could
make Democrats like Joe Biden rethink their
tough on crime pivot. Maybe, you know, go to
a more solve it from the roots type of thing.
Speaker 1: Why would. So you're saying the fact
that Brandon Johnson won with his we're going
to reform but support police sort of mentality.
Would that make Biden change his mind about
his? Why would it make Biden change his mind?
Speaker 2: Well, I mean, Biden has seemed
like he's going for a more traditional,
tough on crime type of thing.
Speaker 1: Oh, I.
Speaker 2: See what you're saying.
Speaker 1: You know why I don't think
that would really influence Biden much.
What makes sense politically at the city
level is different than what makes sense at
the state level and certainly for running
as a presidential campaign. So I don't
think Biden would be moved much by what
worked in Chicago for a mayoral race.
Speaker 2: What about, like other city
Democrats like Eric Adams or somebody like that?
Speaker 1: That may be that may be that. It could,
although, you know, all of these mayors
often think and it might be true,
that their city's circumstances are different
than others. And so they really shouldn't go
by what other mayors do. It's just a kind of a
general thought that often is in mayors minds.
Speaker 2: Okay. Well, I guarantee you that if the
opposite had happened and if Paul Vallas had won,
that people like Eric Adams would be shouting
from the rooftops like this is proof that,
yeah, Democrats need to get more tough
on crime. We need harsher, you know,
charges for felons and everything like that.
Speaker 1: You're probably right. You're
probably right as far as that goes. Yeah, I
know. But I don't expect to see Biden adjust
much as a bit on the basis of what happened
in Chicago to answer the first question.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, I wish she
would, but, yeah, I guess he'll
probably continue as he's going into 2024.
Speaker 1: I believe so. KC from Kansas,
always great to hear from you.
Speaker 2:
Okay. Thank you. All right.
Speaker 1: There he goes.